OK.
Let's get right into audience questions.
The first one is about Mike Pence.
David Wood replacing Mike Pence help Donald
Trump get reelected.
Would it help him in the polls?
So it's extremely unlikely that replacing
Pence would help Trump.
And it has the serious potential to hurt Donald
Trump.
And there's a few things you have to understand
about V.P. picks, V.P. picks, the situation.
The risk reward with the vice presidential
pick is asymmetrical.
And what I mean by that is a bad V.P. pick
can hurt you much more than a good V.P. pick
can help you because a good V.P. pick essentially
causes no drama, causes no scandals, stays
out of the way, is a reasonably OK debater
so that in the not particularly highly viewed
vice presidential debate, they hold their
own and they essentially just they know the
talking points.
They don't get hugely embarrassed.
You know, Sarah Palin in her V.P. debate really
didn't do well, but it still didn't really
hurt McCain Palin that much.
I mean, it already wasn't going particularly
well for them.
But on the other hand, if you have a great
V.P., they don't do that much for you.
And so that's why the ace asymmetrical nature
to me would suggest that unless pense is a
problem for Trump, it's risky to replace him.
And you also have to remember replacing your
V.P. is a sign that something is wrong, that
the very news of replacing the V.P. if Trump
were to do it, even if he takes Pence and
replaces him with someone like equally.
Okay, that could be a wash.
But the news that there is chaos and disorganization
with, you know, were days before the convention
at this point, the Republican National Convention
that could actually hurt Donald Trump.
And there if we look at Pence specifically,
you could also make the case that he's complimentary
to Trump in some way.
I know that Trump now pretends to be religious
and he says when he was in his late 60s, he
stopped being pro-choice and now he's against
abortion and all of this stuff.
You know, he reads the Bible.
I don't believe any of it.
But to the extent that anybody does or doesn't
believe it.
Mike Pence is evangelical critic.
Credentials probably help Trump in some key
states with the evangelical base, which, again,
white evangelicals.
We'll talk about this later, actually.
White evangelicals tend to vote Republican.
Would they be turned off from Trump if Pence
wasn't there?
I don't know.
So to me, a bad V.P can really be a problem,
whereas a good V.P. just kind of keeps chugging
along.
Pence, in terms of demographics, could actually
be good for Trump and a replacement itself
could signal trouble and could backfire.
Now, the one thing I am interested in that's
that's maybe a little bit different this time
around is we are going to have a Democratic
female V.P. candidate debating a white evangelical
older male Republican in the V.P. debate.
Now, if you think back to Palin versus Biden
back in 2008, Sarah Palin is just not as quick
or or well versed in policy or skilled at
debating as is Kamala Harris.
But the dynamics were where you had the Democratic
white male debating against the younger Republican
woman.
And that is a different dynamic, particularly
in these times where xenophobia is now welcomed
into the open by the presidency of Donald
Trump.
The the racist right wingers are more willing
than ever to say the things that they were
probably always thinking, etc..
I am interested in what the sort of sidebar
around the debate, what is going to be the
right wing coverage?
How are they going to deal with Kamala Harris
if Birther 2.0 is any sign?
The early questions about is Kamala Harris
actually eligible to be V.P.?
It could get very, very ugly with a woman
of color on the Democratic side debating evangelical
white Republican Mike Pence.
That's in September.
Actually, no.
I believe that the V.P. debate is not even
until October.
So we have some time unless it gets canceled.
But I think that's going to be interesting.
But should Trump replace Pat Pence?
Probably not.
Probably not